madame marois pour espérer devenir
majoritaire vise un certain nombre de
circonscriptions l'a beaucoup dit depuis
une semaine des circonscriptions
caquistes il y en a trois dans la
couronne nord de montréal qui sont
vraiment très représentative de cette
lutte à venir
saint jérôme inutile de vous dire que le
parti québécois y tient avec la
candidature de pierre karl péladeau il
ya blainville également qu'ils étaient
kaki ce qui est toujours khakis et
groulx on a choisi regroupe aujourd'hui
donc juste au nord de montréal
groulx c'est martine desjardins
candidate du parti québécois claude
surprenant candidat de la cac qui ne
savait pas il ya une semaine lui qui
faisait de la politique parce que hélène
daneault la députée sortante de la caq a
décidé le jour du déclenchement la
semaine dernière de ne pas se
représenter et vicky et marc représente
le parti libéral
j'allais me promener donc dans groulx il
y à quelques heures voici ce que ça
donne
dont martine desjardins ce présent que
je veux c'est jouer depuis que je
pourrai bon c'est très bon oui j'aime se
conjugue à sion 10 francs du fonds
martine desjardins quelqu'un qui aimait
tant quelqu'un qui est parti depuis deux
ans un voyage très loin qui revient et
qui va votre photo avec le sigle du
parti québécois c'est quand même
renversant qu'on prend du recul la honte
on vous situer à 12 ans refuser la même
année maroc etc
je laisserai la machine qu'elle n'a pas
vu là où vous l'avez l'intelligence et
la photo c'est la photo officielle en
fait qu'il avait posé problème mais le
sera jamais j'ai quelqu'un de très
professionnel qui respecte tous les
postes
puis on a droit de cheminée la wii
acheminement vous avez le feu est elle
arrivée là parce que vous étiez vous
étiez pas du tout dans ces cas là en
fait j'étais plutôt favorable à
plusieurs idées du parti québécois
notamment la question de la souveraineté
en trodes cet automne notamment la
charte
la question des inégalités hommes femmes
très je suis très favorable et donc
évidemment il ya plusieurs éléments mais
c'est sûr que la question de la
politique cela m'intéressait et
m'intéresse depuis longtemps s'engage
pas dans le mouvement étudiant prend pas
la tête du plus gros groupe jeune au
québec sans être intéressé par la
politique mais pour moi ça allait venir
un peu plus tard raison pour laquelle
j'ai sauté maintenant c'est que je
sentais avec avec les médias au 10e jour
s'avèrent quatrième pouvoir oui mais en
même temps le pouvoir de l'action il est
vraiment dans l'action politique selon
moi et j'ai voulu faire le souffle d'un
prix à payer pour sujette à l'aise vous
devez en douce et l'indexation des frais
de scolarité je dois donner le choix
exactement le dossier des droits de
scolarité la dossier de l'accessibilité
pour moi c'est réglé depuis sa main 2013
d'ailleurs les étudiants ont accueilli
très favorablement le plan qui a été
proposé à la fin du sommet
et ça a été vraiment applaudi lancée
prenant une des plus grosses victoires
du mouvement étudiant ce que c'est
négocier là notamment sa question
d'accepter les président est conscient
et il pas pour les peuples use mais
c'est ça qu'il faut défendre évidemment
les étudiants aux intérêts que l'on a et
lorsque je me suis présenté la table
j'avais un mandat de négociation un
mandat de représenter et de plus en fait
ça serait que l'activité allait être
maintenue parce que l'on parle des
libéraux qui non seulement aux immortels
nombreux scolaires témoins mentalement
d'être ma vielle et président bourse
peuvent être à l'aise avec l'indexation
je suis à l'aise avec les plats complets
je vais vraiment pour moi là c'est pas
juste la question des droits de qualité
c'est réglé depuis très longtemps et
j'ai pas le goût de commencer à
reprendre le dossier des droits d'accès
c'est un vieux schnock c'est pas ta
douce pour moi c'est réglé je défends
plus comme comme candidate aux élections
de groulx je défend plus les étudiants
dans leur ensemble je défends l'ensemble
des concitoyens de circonscription et
donc je ne veux pas revenir sur dossier
pour moi est réglé c'est tout vous allez
faire campagne aux côtés de pierre boué
qui a remis en question québec que six
policiers de centre-droite un homme
d'affaires remettre en question même la
formule rand l'adhésion automatique un
syndicat cotisations cetera encore une
fois le martin desjardins de 2014 et
thales ont fait campagne ça veut pas
dire qu'on est pas les mêmes idées au
niveau de notre opinion par exemple sur
le syndicalisme québécois
par exemple dans la circonscription
notamment uni fort qui est un des très
gros syndicats canadiens québécois et je
plutôt favorable justement au maitien la
forme pure n excédera et j'ai vraiment
pas perdre avec défendre et débattront
points avec monsieur péladeau au contrat
je pense que dans le parti québécois est
une coalition de gens de leaders de
taille de forton le vu les candidats et
qui était à la tête de plusieurs
organismes qui se présente on voit que
ces délits d'année et donc
en fait je les fais avec madame marois à
l'époque elle était première ministre
elle est encore là mais elle et qu'elle
était premier ministre au sommet sur
l'éducation j'ai défendu mon poing
jusqu'à de défendre avec n'importe qui
est ce que vous êtes heureuse que l'on
parle davantage de souveraineté que l'on
aurait pu penser parce que je fais mes
yeux mais heureuse de s'allonger
ben oui très heureuse qu'on parle de
souveraineté enfin qu'on n'est pas qu'on
soit plus gênés de se dire souverainiste
et même des gens d'affaires qui se
disent souverainistes dire que c'était
tabou il fallait absolument être de
gauche pour pouvoir se dire souveraine
est seul on voit des gens de toutes les
tailles qui disent non moi j'y crois en
fait un site aller chercher cette
nouvelle liberté allait reprendre le
contrôle de nos valeurs de notre nous
ressources et donc je suis très emballé
en fait de versailles plus de jeunes
aussi qui n'ont pas peur de le dire
n'oublions pas le dot nos électeurs là
qui vont voter pour la première fois il
avait fourni des 95 ils n'ont pas connu
et donc ça va faire j'en choisis un
référendum rapidement rapidement ou pas
rapidement pour vrai pour moi ce n'est
pas sur la question la question c'est
qu'on se pose vraiment la question est
ce qu'on en veut un le livre blanc
s'agissant des gens sont cons en vain
c'est sûr qu'on en veut un référendum
mais je veux pas non plus brusques et
légendes à ses fins cription ici mes
concitoyens oui moi je suis pour
mesdames marware parce qu'on a besoin de
changement
falloir une femme au pouvoir j'aimerais
sur 40 avec force pour pour voir qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui peut emporter ou à
québec vraiment pas qu'elle allait me
dit même si éventuellement vous pourriez
voté non au référendum ce programme
c'est après ce coup ci on va commencer
par claude surprenant bonjour je voulais
être dans votre circonscription vous lie
à peine dix jours
vous n'aviez aucune digue se regarde
effectivement je dirais que quand même
une vingtaine d'années que je songe à
devenir un candidat effectivement c'est
d'être il ya quelques jours
accueilli par les processus et pourquoi
facturation j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait
un besoin effectivement urgent de
changer les choses
l'expérience que j'ai eue au cours des
quatre dernières années de démarrer une
entreprise en technologie et vis-à-vis
des difficultés qu'on a rencontrés bien
souvent nous référer à des entités acte
extérieur du québec pour la recherche de
financement par exemple un lien manque
au québec
et puis leur parle alain par la halle
aux sucres et d'autre beaucoup et c'est
un consensus qui avait qu'il faut
tourner tourner la roue newcastle jets
dans le milieu donc des affaires où vous
êtes quelqu'un de voir pierre karl
péladeau le symbole de la grosse
réussite au québec où est ce que ça vous
à dire web parce que je ne suis pas
trompé de parti vraiment un port en fait
en toute franchise dans la réflexion au
départ moi je suis un nationaliste et je
veux aider beaucoup audio à aider le
québec à occuper sa place
par contre du poteau leonid un
indépendantiste et puis donc et puis
d'ailleurs en voyant le discours de plus
en plus radicale
j'ai dû parti québécois ça me convient
qu'il ya cac c'est le bon personnel dans
lequel un jeune homme de compromis de
concession de discussion et puis quoi
que ce soit bon endroit et peut être que
lui pour bon endroit
le fait qu'on parle j'ai vu que l'agencé
ne ferait qu on parle de soi indique dr
karl péladeau c'est ça comment vous
sentez vous êtes content
d'un côté on va attendre on va attendre
il commence ses cinq une semaine c'est
quoi vos craintes
c'est un coq du tocsin qui brassent la
marmite des votes qatar 11 trop
c'est pas bon visualisation par wired en
une de la démocratie la boue
bon alors je vais madame est mort c'est
pas un terrain c'est pas le terrain plus
facile pour les lieux d'un roux ici
c'est pas un terrain extrêmement
difficile non plus en prononçant le
prendre pour acquis pour cet intérêt
qu'ils aient déjà obtenu avec monsieur
les coteaux de mes trois se soumettront
poste 3 c'est un intérêt qui est à nous
on les regagner terrain qui avait été à
nous par 303 vote
alors on cet intérêt où il ya une bonne
base militante libérale
alors cette année ça vouloir vendre la
peau de l'ours
on sent vraiment que les libéraux se
réveille beaucoup cette année compte
tenu de la situation compte tenu du
contexte
on sent que les libéraux sont avec nous
cette année beaucoup qu'est-ce qui les
réveille il selon vous ce que c'est
parce qu'on parle plus que l'on croyait
de souveraineté la souveraineté choque
beaucoup ici dans groulx avec nos
municipalités qui sont ici rosemère
sainte thérèse boisbriand en un petit
parti grainville ça les choque
énormément
martine desjardins dérange beaucoup
dérange beaucoup ce n'est pas
nécessairement le meilleur couple parti
québécois d'avoir amie martine
desjardins ici pourquoi se libéra martin
est très stigmatisés madame desjardins
très stigmatisés elle reflète beaucoup
ce qui s'est passé avec les étudiants
c'était une leader pas nécessairement le
côté positif c'est un leader qui fait du
bruit qui est sorti dans la rue quatre
carrés rouges bruille du vandalisme
attention je dis pas que c'est elle qui
crée le vandalisme mais si tout est
associé à ça donc ici d'un gros on parle
beaucoup de gens qui sont des familles
ce ne sont pas des gens qui vont dans la
rue ici on parle beaucoup de familles et
6 parce qu'on cherche la chicane la
division on cherche vraiment à établir
le futur pour nos enfants ici